il y a un monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues
c'est avec plaisir que nous recevons
pour la première fois devant notre
commission Monsieur Hervé Berville le
nouveau secrétaire d'État chargé de la
mer placé auprès de la première ministre
comme vous vous en doutez nous
souhaitions particulièrement vous
entendre dans le cadre de l'examen
prochain par le Sénat du projet de Loire
relatif à l'accélération de la
production d'énergie renouvelable projet
qui était déposé sur le bureau de notre
assemblée le 26 septembre dernier je
rappelle qu'en application du décret
d'attribution publié en juillet dernier
votre secrétariat d'État est associé aux
politiques publiques en matière de
protection du littoral et d'énergie
marine renouvelable en lien avec le
ministère de la transition énergétique
de Madame Agnès rue nachée qui est en
charge de développement des énergies
renouvelables bien sûr cette rencontre
est également l'occasion d'aborder votre
feuille de route pour 2023 s'agissant
des affaires maritimes je laisserai les
collègues qui souhaitent vous interroger
à ce sujet tout à l'heure
sans plus tarder entrons dans le vif du
sujet avec le projet de loi relatif à
l'accélération de la production
d'énergie renouvelables qui comporte un
type dédié à l'éolien en mer je
souhaiterais en particulier aborder
trois points
première observation sur l'éolien amer
il semble exister un véritable paradoxe
français notre pays dispose du deuxième
gisement devant éolien marin le plus
important d'Europe derrière le
Royaume-Uni pourtant nous sommes très en
retard par rapport à nombre de nos
voisins européens pour déployer cette
énergie tandis que le Royaume-Uni
possède déjà plus de 10 GW de puissance
installées et l'Allemagne plus de 7 la
France apaise tout juste à mettre en
fonction son premier parc éolien
offshore à Saint-Nazaire qui disposera
d'une capacité de
480 MW
le retard s'accumule et l'objectif fixé
par la PPE de disposer de six gigawatts
de capacité à installer en 2020 avait
déjà été reporté à 2028 récemment le
président de la République
pourtant annoncé un relèvement des
objectifs à 18 GW pour 2035 et 40 pour
2050 ce renforment se renforcement de
nos ambitions et louables mais il semble
très difficile à concrétiser sans une
véritable accélération du processus je
rappelle qu'en moyenne il faut 10 ans en
France pour permettre un exploitation un
parc éolien en mer contre 5 ans en
moyenne dans l'Union européenne hors de
la vie de nombreux acteurs les
dispositions du projet de loi sur
l'éolien en mer permettrait tout au long
de tout au plus de gagner quelques mois
sur l'ensemble du processus
ce ministre qu'elle regarde portez-vous
sur les raisons de ce retard français en
matière de déploiement de l'éolien
offshore votre ministère identifie-t-il
des pistes complémentaires pour nous
permettre d'aller plus vite dans un
deuxième temps je souhaite vous
interroger sur les autres l'énergie
marine renouvelable qui ne sont pas
traitées par le projet de loi je pense
en particulier
aux énergies ou le motrices
marémotrice et à l'énergie thermique des
mers le gouvernement ont identifie-t-il
des mesures pour favoriser les
investissements publics et les
investissements privés dans ces énergies
marines émergentes qui sont qui en sont
encore pour la plupart un stade
expérimental
enfin je vous propose aborder la
question de la place des ports dans le
déploiement des énergies maritimes
renouvelables ce qui me permettra de
faire la transition avec le projet de
budget que le Sénat examinera dans
quelques semaines situé à l'interface
entre le domaine terrestre et maritime
les ports seront amenés à accueillir de
nombreux activités nouvelles pour
accompagner la transition énergétique où
les activités industrielles
telles que nécessaire à la fabrication à
l'assemblage des composants des
éoliennes pensons à la logistique
nécessaire la construction à
l'exploitation des sites de production
d'énergie en mer mais aussi aux
activités de maintenance l'aménagement
d'espace adapté à ces activités va
nécessiter d'importance d'investissement
dans les années à venir le gouvernement
a-t-il prévu d'accompagner
financièrement les ports dans cette
transition ce ministre je vous laisse à
présent répondre aux différents points
et avant de céder la parole à Didier
mandelier rapporteur du projet de loi
sur les énergies renouvelables ainsi
qu'à l'ensemble de mes collègues c'est
le Ministre de la parole
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
vous m'entendez bien merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président d'abord vous dire
que c'est un plaisir d'être ici devant
vous pour la première fois dans le cadre
non seulement de l'analyse et puis de
l'examen du texte sur l'accélération des
énergies renouvelables mais également
pour vous faire part au fond de manière
assez rapide et de manière la plus
exhaustive possible ce sera pas
totalement possible de la feuille de
route qui est la mienne à la tête du
sucre dans les d'État à la mer d'abord
vous dire que la mère la politique
maritime et c'est l'objet aussi de se
rattachement près de la première
ministre et tu une priorité pour le
gouvernement et je crois qu'une priorité
pour vous aussi et pour les élus locaux
et nationaux que vous êtes puisque la
politique maritime la mère on a la
chance d'avoir en France le deuxième
espace maritime au monde on voit bien
que la mer notamment ce qui se passe
dans l'Indo de Pacifique est un lieu de
conflictualisation renforcé c'est le
chef d'état-major de la marine qui le
dit souvent la Chine tous les quatre ans
refait l'équivalent de la marine
française et on voit bien que les enjeux
maritimes sont au cœur au fond de deux
priorités ou en tout cas de deux
impératifs pour nous le premier celui du
dérèglement climatique de l'urgence
écologique et qu'on ne pourra pas
traiter la question du règlement
climatique sans s'attaquer à la question
de la protection des océans et puis le
deuxième enjeu et qui fait de la mère et
de la question maritime un enjeu
prioritaire c'est que la mère est au
cœur de l'enjeu de souveraineté
économique et que à la fois dans ce que
Russell la mère en termes de ressources
mais en même temps ce qu'elle peut nous
permettre et vous l'avez évoqué tout à
l'heure en terme de transition
énergétique en termes bien évidemment de
souveraineté alimentaire la mer est au
cœur de du dérèglement climatique de
l'enjeu écologique et de l'enjeu de
souveraineté et économique et donc la
feuille de route qui m'a été fixée par
le Président de la République par la
première ministre s'articule autour de
trois priorités la première c'est bien
évidemment la protection
[Musique]
pardon
à la rentrée d'eau salée aussi comme on
le voit dans les outre-mer dans nos
terres et qui a un impact notamment sur
l'agriculture donc ça c'est la première
priorité la protection des océans de la
biodiversité marine la deuxième c'est
bien évidemment le développement de
l'économie maritime et le soutien anneau
modèle de pêche parce que vous le savez
très bien dans la diversité des
territoires que vous représentez on a
des modèles de pêche diverses il faut je
crois les protéger les préserver on voit
bien qu'on a un enjeu notamment pour
installer de nouveaux pêcheurs on a un
enjeu sur la décarbonation des navires
et on a un enjeu aussi pour continuer à
avoir une économie locale puisque
l'économie maritime en général une
économie qui est localisée
territorialisée et qui crée des emplois
partout sur notre magnifique littoral et
puis le troisième enjeu vous l'avez
évoqué monsieur le Président c'est celui
au fond de la coordination et de la
planification en mer on voit bien que le
littoral la mer fait l'objet d'une
multiplication et d'une densification de
ces usages avant la mer était plutôt
faut réserver on le sait au pêcheur
maintenant on voit bien qu'il y a une
accumulation en tout cas d'accélération
des activités touristiques il y a
maintenant l'implantation des énergies
renouvelables il y a la question de la
cohabitation des usages et donc c'est à
ce ministère au secrétariat d'État à la
mer que l'on doit mettre en œuvre cette
planification des usages en mer en le
faisant en lien avec les départements
avec les communautés de communes avec
les régions le faire parce que on a des
objectifs qui peuvent paraître parfois
contradictoires qui au fond ne le sont
pas tellement mais qui nécessitent et
bien d'avoir cette concertation et de
travailler ensemble pour à la fois
répondre aux enjeux écologiques mais
aussi aux enjeux énergétiques aux enjeux
de d'aménagement du territoire et aux
enjeux touristiques donc c'est les trois
priorités de la feuille de route avec
une méthode qui est basée sur au fond
trois dimensions principales un partir
du terrain et c'est pour ça que depuis
ma nomination
c'est de me déplacer autant que faire ce
peu dans tous les territoires c'est bien
évidemment Boulogne-sur-Mer avec ce
magnifique port de pêche qui fait la
fierté de notre pays c'est aussi en
Corse pour là aussi à la fois répondre
aux urgences et puis travailler avec
tous les élus définition d'une stratégie
maritime c'est la Bretagne je me permets
de le dire ici étant bien évidemment élu
breton sur la aussi la définition d'une
stratégie pour cette région mais c'est
également la Gironde le Pays Basque au
fond faire en sorte d'avoir une
stratégie nationale mais adaptée aux
spécificités du territoire et aux
attentes et aux enjeux des élus le
deuxième et ça c'est un point qui est
pour moi fondamental c'est de renforcer
la présence et l'influence de la France
dans les institutions européennes sur
ces enjeux de politique maritimes et de
politique de pêche la politique de la
pêche notamment c'est une politique
européenne c'est une politique commune
et au fond trop souvent cette politique
maritime la pêche a été la variable
d'ajustement de de des différentes
politiques publiques et un gros travail
qui a été fait notamment sur la question
du brexit et des licences mais on doit
constamment dire rappeler à nos
partenaires européens que
l'enjeu maritime est un enjeu
prioritaire pour nos politiques
européennes et qu'on doit se battre pour
être présent et pour défendre nos
pêcheurs pour également défendre nos
stratégie sur le déploiement des
énergies marines renouvelables et puis
aussi étant capacité de monter en
puissance partout dans les territoires
ultramarins pour faire face aussi à ce
qui est une réalité la pêche illicite
qui est une réalité des attaques contre
aussi
la biodiversité marine un peu partout
dans nos outre-mer par d'autres pays qui
sont un peu moins regardants sur le
sujet et puis la troisième dimension de
ce que l'on souhaite développer c'est se
baser sur la science et l'innovation on
a la chance d'avoir en France une
formidable équipe de de recherche ça va
de du de l'IRD à l'Ifremer
[Musique]
excellence de la recherche française
pour répondre à vos questions de manière
très concrète monsieur le Président sur
ce que vous m'avez indiqué sur gagner du
temps notamment sur les projets éoliens
en mer j'imagine que vous l'avez évoqué
avec la présidente Chantal ce sera le
cas aussi avec ma collègue Agnès je
crois que le premier ranger la priorité
qui doit être la nôtre avant même de
parler de simplification avant même de
parler de textes de là ça doit être
l'enjeu de la planification parce que ce
qui fait la différence entre un parc
éolien qui au fond
plutôt bien fonctionné ou à fait l'objet
d'un consensus notamment avec les
pêcheurs avec les élus locaux et un
autre qui fonctionne un peu moins bien
c'est d'abord la planification la
planification ça veut dire quoi c'est
très concrètement la concertation avec
tous ceux qui utilisent l'espace
maritime c'est très concrètement au lieu
de quand on fait un projet d'éol au lieu
de fermer tout le parc totalement
pendant tous les travaux c'est le divisé
en 4 pour permettre à ce que les
pêcheurs continuent d'aller pêcher dans
une de ces zones c'est de réfléchir au
retour aussi des activités après que le
parc soit déployé bref c'est une méthode
qui se fait partout en terre aussi et
qui se fait quand vous êtes un élu local
qui se fait quand vous êtes une
collectivité locale et au fond c'est de
déployer cette méthode de planification
d'énergie marine renouvelables et on
voit bien dans les autres pays européens
je sais que vous êtes un certain nombre
d'avoir fait aussi ces déplacements ces
voyages d'études et on le voit en France
ce qui change la donne c'est la
planification et de se dire sur la
concertation c'est le retour aussi des
usages après que le parc ait été déployé
développé et sur la prise en compte des
attentes des différents usagers
notamment des pêcheurs mais aussi des
élus locaux je crois que c'est là où on
va pour on va permettre de d'accélérer
les choses parce que en prenant un peu
plus de temps au début on en gagnera
dans toute la phase de déploiement de
ces parcs éoliens et de ses projets qui
sont indispensables encore une fois pour
la transition énergétique de notre pays
sur notre capacité à sortir de notre
dépendance aux énergies fossiles donc
moi je crois beaucoup à la concertation
à la planification et la planification
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire c'est à dire
dans le cadre notre amant du texte de
loi c'est d'avoir une
comment dirais-je une une planification
globale et c'est tout ce qui sera
proposé dans le texte de loi avec
notamment dans le cadre de la Stratégie
nationale mairie littorale qui se fait
dans le cadre du CNML du Conseil
national de la mère et du littorale qui
au fond le Parlement de la mer et qui
inclut des sénateurs qui inclut des
députés qui incluent des personnalités
du monde maritime qui inclut des élus
locaux c'est là on va devoir définir
ensemble et on se donne un objectif
d'ici 2023 ces stratégies qui sera
ensuite déclinée en fonction des façades
maritimes donc vous voyez un espagnol
bien sûr alors que je vais revenir et je
répondrai à toutes vos questions sur le
sujet mais au-delà de la simplification
administrative et de la simplification
législative moi je crois beaucoup à
l'intelligence collective et on voit
bien que la planification notre capacité
à faire de la concertation elle est
indispensable pour pouvoir faire des
projets qui ont du sens et surtout qui
fassent l'objet d'un consensus partout
sur les territoires et je vous dis ça en
étant un élu d'un territoire on a eu un
des premiers parc celui de Saint-Brieuc
ou là la concertation là aussi a fait
l'objet de beaucoup de de débats et
parfois de controverse le deuxième point
de votre question monsieur le Président
c'était sur les autres types d'énergie
marine là aussi on travaille en
parallèle de ce qui est développé il y a
des projets tests pilotes qui ont été
développés un peu partout sur le
territoire c'est en Normandie on a eu un
projet dans le Morbihan aussi il y a eu
un projet qui a été développé
sur des énergies marines et donc tout ça
on le fait en lien aussi avec les
collectivités locales notamment avec les
régions pour essayer de trouver au fond
la solution qu'il a plus adaptée au
territoire et qui nous permet de
déployer des alternatives aux énergies
fossiles le plus rapidement possible on
le fait en lien avec des agences que
vous connaissez bien comme l'ADEME ou en
lien avec des institutions publiques
comme des pays qui nous permettent de
financer ce type d'innovation sachant
que bien évidemment
ce sera pas dans un horizon deux ou
trois ans et donc il faut qu'on continue
en parallèle à travailler à déployer des
technologies qui ont fait la preuve de
leur efficacité sur la question de la
place des ports parce que c'est un enjeu
essentiel on l'a vu qu'on était
notamment à Saint-Nazaire
au fond il n'y aura pas de véritable
stratégie de déploiement des énergies
renouvelables si on n'a pas une
stratégie également portuaire beaucoup
de vos collègues je pense ici à Michel
vaspark était sénateur décoda mort ne
voyait pas là simplement une
focalisation sur la Bretagne mais je
sais qu'il avait travaillé sur la
question des ports et puis il y a
d'autres collègues aussi que j'ai lu un
certain nombre de rapports la semaine
prochaine nous aurons une réunion avec
Clément Beaune ministre des Transports
et puis tous les gestionnaires de port
et les maires des principaux ports de
notre pays pour justement définir une
stratégie pas étatique portuaire mais
une stratégie nationale parce que ce que
les retours que l'on a des premiers
parcs qui ont été développés c'est qu'on
a besoin d'accélérer de faire
différemment sur le développement des
ports et donc ça veut dire parfois des
adaptations législatives pour permettre
et bien de d'avoir des centres de
maintenance c'est aussi libérer du
foncier pour pouvoir développer la
capacité portuaire
à deux c'est pores qui vont devoir là
aussi accueillir un certain nombre
d'activités et donc pour le faire il
faut qu'on le fasse de manière
collective et c'est à dire que dans la
stratégie qui sera la nôtre aussi sur la
décarbonation on voit bien qu'il y a
beaucoup de régions beaucoup de ports
qui ont envie d'être les premiers sur la
décarbonation sur l'hydrogène bleu sur
Lidl gris sur Lidl vert et donc là aussi
on essaie de définir le plus rapidement
possible en lien avec la stratégie
nationale de la mer et du littoral et
bien au fond une feuille de route une
méthode et ensuite des investissements
qui seront dans le cadre des différents
projets de loi de finance que vous aurez
à voter qui seront dans le cadre aussi
de la stratégie des différentes régions
qui seront dans le cadre pourquoi pas de
France 2030 pour avoir à côté de cette
stratégie nationale de la mer et
électorale une stratégie pour nos ports
parce que si on veut des énergies
marines renouvelables il nous faut à
côté et c'est ce qui avait très bien dit
d'ailleurs la présidente de la région
Pays de la Loire et aussi la présidente
de l'Occitanie que la stratégie
portuaire était centrale dans la
définition d'une stratégie des énergies
marines renouvelables voilà ce que je
pouvais vous dire sur les quelques
questions que vous m'avez je me
permettrai de terminer si vous
m'autorisez sur de sujets qui sont pour
moi fondamentaux parce qu'ils sont liés
à la mer et je sais qu'ils intéressent
aussi beaucoup de vos collègues qui sont
sur des territoires littoraux le premier
c'est sur la pêche si vous me le
permettez parce que notre stratégie
maritime elle ne doit et ne peut se
faire qu'en lien avec aussi le
développement d'une stratégie d'avenir
pour nos pêcheurs je ne més estime pas
les difficultés on a une juxtaposition
de de difficultés de crise pour nos
pécheurs à la fois le brexit le covid la
guerre en Ukraine qui a renchérit le
coup du carburant dès juillet on a mis
en oeuvre un allongement une
prolongation des aides carburant on est
le seul pays en Europe à l'avoir fait je
me suis battu on s'est battu très
fortement pour avoir cette capacité à
étendre les aides de carburant c'est
8 millions d'euros pour les pêcheurs on
sait aussi battus pour augmenter le
plafond d'aide carburant pour nos
pêcheurs qui est à 65000 euros qui est
passé maintenant à 105000 euros et on va
se battre pour continuer à le passer
120 130 140 000 euros dans le cadre de
des différentes révisions de tous ces
plafonds pourquoi on le fait parce qu'on
a un modèle de pêche nous qui est plutôt
un modèle de pêche artisanal comparé à
d'autres pays parce qu'on a un modèle de
pêche qui au fond mais au cœur de ce que
l'on doit faire un véritable modèle
social d'autres pays on fait le choix
eux de mettre sur le banc de touche leur
pêcheurs en attendant des jours
meilleurs arrivent nous on a fait le
choix de continuer à ce qu'il sorte en
mer puisque derrière quand on a un
pêcheur c'est 4 emplois à terre parce
que derrière il y a des marayures
d'ailleurs il y a des industriels qui
transforment aussi ce poisson là et donc
on avait besoin de continuer à avoir ses
activités de pêche donc on a maintenu
cette carburants qui vont continuer là
aussi jusqu'au au moins mis novembre en
parallèle de ça sur la question de la
politique de pêche et au fond comment on
prépare l'avenir c'est d'avoir une
politique ambitieuse sur la
décarbonation des navires de pêche et
donc j'ai annoncé aux Assises de la
pêche un fondamorçage de 6 millions
d'euros pour la décarbonation des
navires de pêche pourquoi parce qu'on
constate au cours des 21 années que les
grandes crises des pêcheurs sont des
crises du carburant et donc il faut
qu'on soit en capacité de les
accompagner et bien à être moins
dépendant du pétrole et moins dépendant
de ces derniers fossiles et donc c'est
toute l'ambition continuera à apporter
et puis je terminerai par un point aussi
c'est sur l'enjeu de la formation de nos
marins de la formation aussi des des
jeunes aux métiers de la mer vous avez
tous dans vos circonscriptions ou dans
vos départements
des lycées maritimes en tout cas des
établissements de formation qui sont
liés au métier de la mer je crois que il
faut qu'on revalorise qu'on redonne du
souffle et aussi des investissements sur
ces métiers de la mer j'y crois
fondamentalement parce que dans
l'objectif du plein d'emploi et bien la
mer la politique maritime et doit être
un des piliers en tout cas ne doit pas
être laisser de côté et donc là dans le
budget qui vous sera proposé et qui vous
est proposé on a là aussi une ambition
d'augmenter les moyens de formation
notamment de l'École nationale
supérieure de la marine pour continuer à
former des marins parce que si on veut
avoir des navires français il nous faut
des marins aussi français avec un modèle
social français et donc c'est la
condition je crois aussi de notre
souveraineté et c'est la condition à ce
qu'on est et bien des métiers de la mer
qui continuent d'atterrir qui seront des
métiers très différents de ce qu'on a
connu il y a 30 40 ans mais je crois que
c'est des métiers qui peuvent faire
rêver c'est des métiers de haute valeur
ajoutée c'est le métier d'expertise et
c'est des métiers qui sont
territorialisés donc voilà ce que je
voulais vous dire parce que c'est un
sujet qui me tient à cœur d'ailleurs
lancement de la Route du Rhum le 6
novembre prochain il y aura un stand du
secrétariat d'État à la mer qui sera
dédié au métier de la mer pour aussi et
bien donner à avoir à nos jeunes et aux
familles tout à diversité des métiers
qui existent dans ce beau domaine voilà
mon monsieur le Président ce que je
pouvais ce que je souhaitais vous dire
en introduction
dire que j'ai toujours plaisir de vous
rencontrer un peu partout sur les
territoires quand je vais en déplacement
qui a beaucoup d'enjeux il y a beaucoup
de sujets il y a beaucoup d'urgences
mais en tout cas on a la tâche pour
essayer de faire de la politique
maritime une politique fondamentale de
ce gouvernement et de notre pays et en
faisant en sorte qu'elle soit à la fois
très locale qui a une dimension
européenne et surtout qu'à
l'international soit reconnue aussi et
spécificités et le leadership de la
France sur le sujet de la politique
maritime merci beaucoup merci monsieur
le ministre je vais donner la parole à
Didier mandeli leur rapporteur puis
après
Philippe Tabarro qui est rapporteur des
crédits chargé du transport maritime
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je vais revenir au sujet qui
nous concerne spécifiquement aujourd'hui
le président va se finir en introduction
la France va devoir résoudre une
équation délicate pour atteindre les
objectifs fixés par le Président de la
République
évidemment
soit accélérer le déploiement des parcs
où il y a offerts en atteignant un
rythme minimal d'attribution d'appels de
l'ordre de 2 Go par an
vous l'avez évoqué 480 mégas installés à
Saint-Nazaire pour le premier et cela
tout en renforçant la concertation afin
d'assurer l'acceptabilité sociale ou la
propriété
qui a pu parfois faire défaut je pense
par exemple au parcologue vous avez cité
à Saint-Brieuc qui a suscité et qui
suscite toujours une vive contestation
locale
la solution de cette équation
résidera dans notre aptitude à organiser
dans l'espace et dans le temps la teinte
des objectifs de déploiement en
associant étroitement toutes les parties
prenantes de nombreux acteurs qu'il
s'agissent des industriels des élus
locaux des nations des riverains
expriment une forme de lassitude
vis-à-vis de la méthode suivie par le
gouvernement qui donne l'impression de
traiter les appels d'offres les uns
après les autres par un coup sans avoir
au préalable une vision globale des
projets envisagés à l'échelle des
différentes façades l'article 12 du
projet de loi de fait dans le bon sens
on permettant aux documents stratégiques
de façade de définir des zones
d'implantation pour de futurs appels
d'offres mais le dispositif proposé
suscite certaines interrogations parmi
les écouteurs que j'ai pu entendre dans
le cadre des auditions
en prévision de rédaction du texte qui
sera présenté à la commission mercredi
prochain
cette planification des projets par le
document stratégique de façade ne sera
que facultative si j'en crois la lettre
de l'article elle ne concernera pas tous
les appels d'offres et ne permettra que
d'identifier des zones potentielles
d'implantation
en outre en attendant en attendant la
révision des DSF qui ne devrait pas
intervenir avant 2024 nous pourrions
perdre du temps pour le lancement des
appels d'offres je rappelle que le
l'élaboration du premier cycle des DSF a
nécessité près de 6 ans de travail en
outre le document stratégique de façade
vise à planifier l'ensemble des
activités liées au littoral et amères il
y a donc un risque soit que l'éolien en
mer phagocyte les autres les autres
usages dans les débats publics soit
qu'il soit diluer parmi tous les enjeux
qui seront abordés alors pour atteindre
l'objectif de 18 Go de puissance
installée en 2035 qui sera sans doute
traduit dans la prochaine loi de
programmation sur l'énergie climat nous
aurions intérêt à planifier c'est un mot
que vous a employé sans attendre de
manière claire et précise les futurs
projets éoliens offshore de façon
globale sur le territoire il nous faudra
associer étroitement les usagers de la
mer évidemment le public les élus locaux
mais aussi disposer une approche globale
si on va être en capacité de distribuer
les objectifs de développement sur les
quatre façades maritimes
ce ministre que répondez-vous aux
acteurs qui expriment méfiance vis-à-vis
de la capacité pour les DSF à intégrer
une planification l'éolien en mer avec
suffisamment de précision et de célérité
surtout avez-vous réfléchi à une méthode
nationale permettant d'identifier des
zones précises d'implantation des
projets au lien en mer avec un
calendrier prévisionnel des appels
d'offres à raison de 5 et 10 ans sachant
que nous pourrions dans ce genre de
démarche intégrer évidemment les
évolutions technologiques et je pense
notamment à certaines techniques qui
permettrait aux technologies qui
permettraient de contribuer à
l'acceptation je pense en question en
particulier aux questions de visibilité
en éloignant les les parcs donc je pense
que nous aurions besoin de travailler
sur ces questions là ensemble pour dans
le cadre de la PPE fixer ses objectifs
donc cette méthode de planification elle
doit être
robuste et elle doit porter ses fruits
pour je le répète être intégré dans la
prochaine PPE en termes d'objectif
donc voilà je pose la question
clairement
avez-vous ou avant nous ensemble la
capacité à travailler au travers de ce
texte aller laboration d'une stratégie
d'une planification qui permette de
prendre en compte l'ensemble des
éléments que je viens d'évoquer les
éléments technologiques
aujourd'hui technologique qui sont
matures qui ne demande qu'à être
déployés et en intégrant bien sûr la
question de l'acceptabilité et que je
traduis concernant l'éolien en mer par
un synonyme de visibilité
merci je vais dans la parole à Philippe
oui merci après vous répondez
votre arrivée au secrétariat d'État à la
mer coïncide avec la refonte
d'administrative et budgétaire des
affaires maritimes qui intègre désormais
de secteur de la pêche et de
l'aquaculture pourriez-vous tout d'abord
nous présenter les grandes lignes du
budget des affaires maritimes pour 2023
en dehors de ces ajouts même si vous
avez évoqué quelques points dans votre
propre luminaire je souhaiterais aborder
deux points relatifs au verdissement du
transport maritime d'abord s'agissant
des navires avec une flotte de commerce
française d'environ 200 navires on
estime à 380 millions d'euros le coût
nécessaire à son renouvellement dont 60
millions pour le seul verdissement or
les armes les armateurs disposent de peu
de soutien public pour absorber le
surcoût le plan de relance te comportait
aucun crédit pour
l'armement maritime quant au plan
d'investissement France 2030 et aux 4
milliards d'euros annoncés pour les
véhicules du futur il ne semble pas
intégrer à ce jour le transport maritime
j'ai donc deux questions d'une part
allez vous remédier à cet oubli pour
conquérir l'objectif fixé par
l'Organisation maritime internationale
de réduire de 50 % d'ici 2050 les
émissions de CO2 liées au transport
maritime d'autre part je souhaiteraient
faire un point sur la mise en oeuvre du
suramortissement vert depuis son
instauration 2020 ce dispositif n'avait
encore jamais pu être mise en oeuvre du
fait de critères d'éligibilité bien trop
restrictif que nous avons assoupli
d'ailleurs en loi de finance initiale
pour 2022 un an après voyez-vous déjà
les effets de cette assouplissement sur
les acquisitions d'équipements verts
pour les navires je souhaiterais
également évoquer le verdissement des
ports auquel le plan de relance avait
consacré 175 millions d'euros les
documents budgétaires de
pour le moins de précision s'agissant de
la ventilation de ces crédits
pourriez-vous nous apporter un éclairage
sur les opérations financées par cette
enveloppe en 2022 et celle prévue en
2023 donnant des exemples notamment en
matière d'infrastructures de report
modal de plus la pandémie mondiale
suivie de l'invasion russe en Ukraine a
rappelé l'agilité sans faille que la
nation exige de ses ports pour assurer
la provisionnement de la chaîne
logistique malgré un sous-investissement
chronique dans les infrastructures
d'accès que nous avons ici bien souvent
décrié sur le ministre a quand un
véritable plan d'investissement en
faveur du développement des
infrastructures de report modal
dans nos GPM enfin une dernière petite
question plus locale m'associant aux
inquiétudes du maire de Vallauris
golgiant dans les Alpes-Maritimes je
souhaite relayer ici un projet
d'extension démesuré d'une ferme aquacol
de 25000 mètres carrés à quelques
encablures des îles de Lérins et de la
baie de Golfe Juan dans les
Alpes-Maritimes que votre directeur de
cabinet connaît fort bien ce projet
questionne fortement car il regroupe
trois concessions éparse en méga
structure équivalente à trois stades de
football à l'opposé d'une pêche
raisonnée locale et d'une protection des
fonds marins nous sommes plusieurs être
intervenus pour nous inquiéter des
risques écologiques de cette
surproduction dans une baie relevant du
réseau Natura 2000 merci monsieur le
ministre
Monsieur miliste Merci beaucoup pour
répondre à monsieur le rapporteur que je
salue d'abord pour la précision de ces
questions et puis pour au fond avoir
dressé le portrait de d'avoir tracé les
lignes de ce que doit être notre
ambition collective donc je réponds à
son invitation bien volontiers de
continuer de travailler ensemble sur
définir exactement ce qui est la
planification et ce que ça veut dire
très concrètement c'est ça qui
m'intéresse c'est pour ça que je suis
ici devant vous c'est pour ça qu'on a vu
le président aussi il a de ça d'un mois
pour évoquer ces sujets que partout où
je me déplace sur les territoires on
échange on
travaille sur la définition de cette
planification vous l'avez dit le texte
de loi permet de mutualiser au fond les
débats publics de façade et vous avez
pointé deux risques le premier c'est
celui que on ne parle que d'éolien en
mer dans les documents de façade ou
qu'on le banalise et qu'on en parle pas
suffisamment je pense que là ça revient
à l'intelligence collective ou en tout
cas à la capacité de discernement des
uns et des autres de faire en sorte
qu'il soit au fond discuter au bon
niveau dans le dans le bon équilibre il
y a des territoires dans le document
stratégique de document stratégiques de
façade ou ce sera le cœur en tout cas
l'un des enjeux prioritaires parce que
il y aura un déploiement un
développement qui sera important et puis
peut-être que dans d'autres et ce sera à
voir avec tous les acteurs ce sera pas
marginal du tout mais ce sera pas
forcément le sujet numéro un parce qu'il
y en a d'autres qui arriveront avant en
tout cas nous ce que l'on souhaite c'est
que on ne comme vous l'avez dit on ne
travaille pas par à coup au fond par
projet par projet sans avoir une
définition globale et donc notre
ambition c'est que notamment dans le
cadre comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure
du CNML du Conseil national de la mer et
du littoral on arrive à définir d'ici
2023 juin 2023 ou en tout cas mi-2023
cette stratégie nationale de la mer et
du littoral qui prend justement tous les
enjeux économiques environnementaux
paysagers
territoriaux énergétiques donc on va
avoir j'ai envoyé les courriers pour que
les présidents des différentes
assemblées installent les les personnes
les personnalités qualifiées qui
participent au SMS et donc on va pouvoir
travailler très rapidement tout un jeu
ensuite il y aura la PPE cette PPE elle
va devoir définir l'enveloppe globale et
ensuite on aura à la définir ensemble et
je ne sais pas vous dire si ce sera pour
l'Atlantique en janvier ou si ce sera
pour la Méditerranée en mars parce que
tout ça on le fera ensemble avec tous
les élus notamment régionaux
départementaux et locaux on aura la
déployer par façade maritime en le
faisant en ayant à l'esprit deux choses
c'est que 1 en effet il faut qu'on ait
d'ambition aussi technologique et donc
faut pas écarter
d'ores et déjà telle ou telle
technologie et donc il faut qu'on avance
en parallèle c'est pour ça que il y a
des projets pilotes qui sont formés
Méditerranée sur tel ou tel technologies
c'est pour ça qu'on continue à soutenir
aussi des inhumations technologiques un
peu partout sur le territoire et donc
pour répondre à votre question c'est en
mi-2023 qu'on aura un tableau plus
précis parce qu'on aura fait cette
concertation avec le CNML avec les élus
régionaux et locaux et qu'on pourra
déterminer au fond par façade maritime
quelle est l'ambition que l'on se donne
et ensuite c'est là où vient aussi cette
question n'a planification il faut là
prendre le temps avec les pêcheurs avec
tous ceux qui participent avec aussi le
ministère de la Défense parce qu'il y a
parfois des zones de défense comprennent
le temps et bien de de déployer et de
regarder très précisément comment ça ça
va se déployer avec un enjeu aussi là
parfois de confusion c'est que parfois
la concertation et pas exactement le
même temps que celui de la communication
et parfois c'est vrai qu'on lance des
exercices une concertation et au fond
nos concitoyens ils ont l'impression que
le projet déjà lancé que tout est déjà
figé alors que c'est pas le cas là on
donne la possibilité à une entreprise de
pouvoir participer à l'appel d'offres ou
là on se lance dans la phase des études
en environnementale et d'impact
écologique et donc pour répondre aussi à
une de votre question qui était
sous-entente c'était que il y a aussi un
enjeu sur le cahier des charges au fond
vous l'évoquez l'acceptabilité de ces
projets là il tient aussi à l'alignement
des éoliennes typiquement au lieu
d'avoir
15 éoliennes sur trois lignes on peut
avoir trois éoliennes sur 15 lignes je
dis ça je sais pas ce qui sera dans le
cahier des charges mais voyez c'est tout
le travail qu'on essaie de faire à
Belle-Île qui a été fait avec les les
élus locaux c'est ce que on discute
aussi au large de la région donc le
cahier des charges sur le positionnement
des éoliennes sur la distance bien
évidemment et sur au fond
déplacement de de ces installations est
un enjeu aussi important puisque c'est
un impact sur la visibilité et sur du
coup l'acceptation donc c'est tout ça
que on va essayer de faire et comme je
vous le disais le point de chute doit
être mis 2023 au fond sans cohérence
avec la PPE que vous aurez à discuter
ici au Parlement
je crois avoir répondu sur le sujet sur
les les autres points évoqués par
Monsieur
le Sénateur sur les grandes lignes du
budget 2023 alors vous savez c'est un un
budget de 140 millions d'euros c'est un
budget qui à l'étal l'année dernière il
y avait une augmentation de 23 millions
d'euros donc on reste dans ces mêmes
proportions c'est un budget qui est
satisfaisant en tout cas qui me
satisfait puisque ça permet de monter en
puissance sur un certain nombre de
sujets prioritaires comme celui de la
formation des marins et donc dans ce
budget il y a
77 millions d'euros pour la présence et
l'intervention de l'État en mer c'est
notamment avec la question du fond
d'intervention maritime qui permet
d'aller accompagner des projets
innovants partout sur les territoires et
on aura à faire là aussi la publicité de
son fondateur maritime dans les
prochains jours c'est 35 millions
d'euros pour les gens de mer notamment
pour l'école nationale supérieure de la
marine c'est 86 millions d'euros et vous
l'avez évoqué pour la flotte de commerce
avec le dispositif que vous connaissez
bien de networge et au fond c'est 86
millions d'euros c'est notre stratégie à
la fois d'accompagnement d'une flotte de
commerce françaises et puis c'est notre
accompagnement sur la décarbonation et
sur le verdissement de notre flotte de
commerce français parce que c'est un
enjeu de société puis c'est un enjeu
aussi d'efficacité économique et puis
c'est 50 millions d'euros pour le budget
pêche notamment sur le contrôle c'est
aussi l'enjeu de la je sais que vous
êtes attentif monsieur le Président sur
l'enjeu d'avoir un plan sur la capture
de cétacés dans le golf de Gascogne donc
voilà un peu la structuration de ce
budget 2023 de mon ministère en
répondant à votre question sur le
dispositif de suramortissement c'était
ça on a des retours qui sont plutôt
positifs donc en tout cas il y a pas de
vocation ici à l'éteindre ou en tout cas
de diminuer dans son ambition pourquoi
on le fait vous avez vu qu'il y a des
débats actuellement sur la question
des profits ou en tout cas de la
taxation ou non d'un certain nombre
d'entreprises moi j'invite toujours nos
concitoyens à regarder pas simplement la
photo mais le film on a la chance
d'avoir des entreprises qui sont au fond
à la pointe sur ces sujets de la flotte
de commerce sur des entreprises qui nous
permettent aussi d'avoir une forme de
souveraineté économique dans le domaine
et donc il faut qu'on continue à les
accompagner à nous appuyer il faut qu'on
ait des exigences environnementales
sociales et c'est ce qu'on porte dans
aussi ce budget là et donc sur les
dispositifs qui ont fait leurs preuves
et qui permettent au fond d'accompagner
notre faute de commerce on continuera de
le faire et de le porter dans les
prochains budgets si ils sont votés bien
évidemment par vos assemblées
sur les autres sujets monsieur le
sénateur sur les ports vous me demandiez
des des exemples de projets
d'accompagnement de la décarbonation
aussi de nos ports je vais vous donner
deux exemples c'est bien évidemment des
des branchements électriques à quai que
nous avons financé c'est le cas
notamment à Marseille c'est des
solutions de décarbonation indiscrètes
innovantes comme le captage de CO2
d'électrolyseur H2 comme un Dunkerque à
europa-port et donc au fond on est dans
une position où il y a des idées des
innovations qui sont portées par par le
port par les ports pardon et on les
accompagne et on les finance en faisant
ça dans le cadre d'une stratégie
nationale pour éviter parfois et bien
des des comment dirais-je des
redondances ou pour le faire de manière
la plus efficace possible donc on va
continuer à le faire et dans le cadre de
vous l'avez évoqué dans le cadre de
France on continuera de le faire à
hauteur de 175 millions d'euros et c'est
pas les projets qui manquent sur le
sujet de la décarbonation et
l'innovation des ports et puis dernier
sujet sur
vous l'avez évoqué sur France 2030 si je
ne m'abuse vous avez raison la dimension
maritime et notamment la dimension du
navire zéro mission était absente de
France 2030 et donc ce qu'on essaie de
porter avec Bruno Bonnel actuellement et
c'était la demande aussi la première
ministre c'est justement d'avoir cette
dimension navire zéro émission et cette
dimension décarbonation des avenir dans
France 2030 et donc on a réuni il y a
deux semaines un comité de pilotage
France 2030 justement sur le sujet de la
mère pour porter l'ambition beaucoup
plus forte de maritimiser France 2030 et
donc aux astuces de la mer à Lille
j'aurai l'occasion de développer un peu
l'ambition qui est la nôtre pour
continuer à accélérer la décarbonation
du secteur il y aura des contribution
qui sont faites nous l'espérons par les
acteurs du secteur mais en tout cas j'ai
commencé avec la pêche 6 millions
d'euros il faudra le faire sur le
transport maritime il faudra une
ambition très forte parce que c'est une
ambition industrielle entrepreneuriale
territoriale et donc si on peut se fixer
un objectif de monter au moins de aller
200 millions d'euros sur cet objectif de
décarbonation de du transport maritime
ce serait je crois un bel objectif qui
mettre qui montrerait que la mer est au
même niveau que les autres secteurs
merci monsieur le ministre je ferai une
réponse écrite très précise sur la
pisidiculture
d'ores et déjà
non je ferai une réponse écrite comme ça
ce sera le plus clair possible pour pour
vous et pour aussi
les concitoyens
merci
je donne la parole de 5 premiers
demandent et après vous répondrez à
Monsieur Dominique
merci monsieur le Président bonjour
monsieur le ministre est heureux de vous
retrouver au Sénat et félicitations pour
votre nomination au gouvernement je
voudrais vous parler de l'objectif
d'atteindre une cinquantaine de parcs
d'ici 2050 le président a inauguré le
premier parquet au lien en mer français
le 22 septembre au dernier à
Saint-Nazaire 80 mâts blancs à 15 km des
côtes avec des pales d'une envergure
d'un Airbus A380 soit près de 80 mètres
ce n'est pas rien et ça nécessite bien
entendu des concertations soutenues les
projets des parcs n'étant pas toujours
bien reçu c'est un 12 de féminisme de le
dire c'est par exemple le cas à
Saint-Brieuc dont il m'a été dit que
vous aviez jugé ce parc ni fait ni à
refaire en tout cas ça avait été le
titre d'un article de presse c'est le
cas aussi à Dieppe le Tréport près de
chez moi ou le projet de construction
d'un parc rencontre l'opposition des
pêcheurs et des habitants depuis des
années alors les habitants on va en
parler puisqu'on en a parlé tout à
l'heure avec Chantal Jouanneau dans le
cadre de la scène
merci chers collègues monsieur Houlgate
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je vous rappelle mais vous le
savez déjà que la Normandie et les
normances sont d'un peuple aussi de
marins pas uniquement des terriens donc
je renouvelle votre invitation à vous
déplacer plus particulièrement à
Cherbourg je voudrais vous poser une
question sur le partage de la valeur
notamment en zone économique exclusive
puisque l'exploitation des ressources
naturelles en D2 elle découle de la
Convention de Montego B la fiscalité
liée à cette exploitation est à la
discrétion de l'État côtier en revanche
la Convention ne transfère des droits
souverains que pour l'État ce qui
semblerait je te parle au conditionnel
exclure les collectivités territoriales
du bénéfice de cette fiscalité donc
avez-vous déjà engagé une réflexion à la
fois sur le niveau de tarification et
puis éventuellement sur l'affectation de
cette recette sachant qu'il y a déjà des
besoins qui ont été identifiés ces
besoins c'est bien évidemment la
protection de la biodiversité marine et
l'approfondissement des connaissances
des milieux et et des mesures de
protection qu'il faudra adopter sur bien
évidemment la sécurité et la sûreté
maritime sur la nécessaire et
éco-transformation de la filière pêche
qui va elle aussi être impactée par le
la réduction donc de cette zone d'usage
et puis éventuellement sur le
développement de coût usage qui pourrait
être justement que coexister avec ces
éoliennes donc avez-vous déjà donc une
réflexion et quid de des retombées sur
les sur les collectivités locales en
espérant que que cette fiscalité ne
vient pas abonder de façon générale le
budget de l'État et et ne puisse pas
servir justement aux besoins qui sont
identifiés
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Monsieur Chevrollier
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
ministre salut votre nomination à ce
beau ministère de la mer dans les enjeux
pour notre pays deuxième zone économique
exclusive sont importants
aussi les enjeux autour de la
biodiversité que vous avez
évoqué à la veille d'ailleurs de la de
la COP15 biodiversité je sais pas si
vous avez prévu de vous y rendre en tout
cas quelle est la feuille de route du
ministère de la mer sur les sujets de
biodiversité et donc sur développement
des énergies renouvelables et
biodiversité les projets éoliens
offshore suscitent de vivre
d'inquiétudes pour la biodiversité
marine et aviaire ces inquiétudes sont
alimentées comme ça vient d'être dit par
le fait qu'on manque de connaissances
précises sur les incidences
environnementales de ces parcs donc
quels sont les déjà les études réalisées
sur le sujet pouvez-vous à ce jour
rassurer les acteurs qui s'inquiètent de
l'impact de ces projets et est-ce que à
ce stade est envisagé d'exclure
certaines zones sensibles des projets de
futurs parcs et quelles pistes sont
envisagées par le gouvernement afin
d'améliorer l'information du public dans
les zones d'implantation enfin puisque
vous avez abordé aussi le sujet de la
pêche qui m'a apprend à proprement
parler ne dépend pas de notre commission
mais le moi je voudrais l'évoquer dans
le lien avec la biodiversité le sujet de
la pêche scène des mersal qui suscite de
vivre
inquiétudes auprès de de des pêcheurs
français puisque c'est une pêche
extrêmement destructrice vous le savez
avec la le déploiement de filet sur
plusieurs kilomètres et donc les
pêcheurs français qui qui s'inquiètent
de cette technique sur les menaces par
rapport à la biodiversité marine sont
expriment une incompréhension par
rapport à la position de l'État français
sur sur cette pêche qui est pratiquée
par des hollandaises que vous pouvez
nous éclairer sur ce sujet là je vous
remercie
merci la parole était madame Bonnefoy
puis après madame privil et puis après
au ministre
pourquoi avoir défendu au niveau
européen cette pêche industrielle contre
une pêche
respectable donc comment justifier cette
pêche climaticide au détriment de nos
pêcheurs et de leur famille donc je vous
pose cette question comme mon collègue
et la deuxième question concerne
plusieurs ONG qui s'inquiètent d'un
projet mené par Total énergie sur les
côtes d'Afrique du Sud visant à
exploiter des gisements de gaz et de
pétrole est-ce que le gouvernement
français est au courant de ce projet
l'État français peut-il laisser faire un
écossible de ce type alors que l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie s'est
prononcé en 2021 pour l'arrêt immédiat
de tout nouvel investissement dans les
énergies fossiles afin des d'atteindre
la neutralité carbone d'ici à 2050 la
cinémat deuxième question
merci
è l'équation des divers usages que l'on
peut faire de l'océan et des mers
c'est-à-dire nous sommes la première
destination touristique au monde donc le
tourisme la pêche comme vous l'avez
rappelé et puis la l'oblige enfin
l'obligation de préserver absolument le
vivant dans les océans puisque le Puy de
carbone alors là on est directement
intéressé le Puy de carbone est lié à la
présence du vivant dans les océans et
que des boucles de rétroaction sont en
train de se mettre en place à cause du
réchauffement climatique de la perte de
biodiversité et donc de la perte de
fixation du carbone dans ces puits de
carbone que sont les océans et les mers
et je souhaiterais vous interroger donc
déjà comment résoudre cette équation
difficile donc faire des priorités mais
également sur
comment vous envisagez parce qu'on a
beaucoup parlé d'éolien en mer mais
l'énergie mécanique de des
océans et due aussi au mouvement qui
sont créés qui s'appelle les marées par
la lune et une production d'électricité
possible en se servant de cette énergie
mécanique pour produire de l'électricité
est-ce que vous comment vous regardez
les projets qui ont déjà eu lieu dans
d'autres pays puisque nous à part
l'usine marée motrice de la Rance qui
date déjà à maintain il y a quelques 60
ans les technologies ont beaucoup évolué
il y a des projets en Écosse qui se sont
développés comment vous les regardez et
est-ce qu'il y a déjà de prévu de futurs
développement de cette énergie là en
France
monsieur le ministre vous avez la parole
merci beaucoup pour la diversité des
questions et leurs qualités
sur le premier sujet sur la question de
des retours au fond et de
la pacte que ça sur la biodiversité déjà
on vous dit que dans le projet de loi
qui vous est présenté qui vous sera
présenté il n'y a rien qui met en cause
et qui ne remet en question notre
volonté et je crois qu'il est partagé
ici de regarder avec beaucoup
d'attention voire même de renforcer la
préservation de cette biodiversité et
donc il y a toute une série d'études de
d'obligation qui doivent et qu'ils
seront mis en oeuvre dans le cadre de
tout projet éolien en mer c'était le cas
avant ça continuera d'être le cas et
d'ailleurs c'est la raison pour laquelle
par exemple le parc au large d'Oléron
n'est pas dans le parc naturel marin et
qu'on continuera à bien évidemment faire
de la biodiversité la préservation de la
biodiversité le pilier de ma stratégie
aussi que ce soit à terre ou en mer
ensuite vous avez évoqué une expression
que j'ai utilisée qui est une expression
mon grand-père utilisait ni feignarder
ça veut dire en fait comme mon
grand-père disait ça ça voulait dire
c'est quelque chose qui a pas été fait
dans les règles de l'art en tout cas
qu'on aurait pu mieux faire et donc je
continue de de le dire quand on regarde
la manière dont ça fait et puis lenteur
avec laquelle ça c'est fait que on a des
leçons à tirer de tout ça et donc pour
répondre à votre question cher sénateur
c'est que quand on regarde l'impact de
ces projets qui ont été fait un peu
partout au Danemark en Angleterre mais
aussi la à Saint-Nazaire rien ne nous
permet de dire que l'on ne peut pas
continuer à développer des projets
éoliens en mer puisque au fond ça permet
de répondre à la question de la
transition énergétique du développement
des énergies marines renouvelables et
que la biodiversité y est préservé même
parfois on assiste à un certain nombre
de choses assez intéressantes avec de la
fixation autour des piliers
biodiversité qui est retrouvé par contre
nous ce que l'on souhaite c'est que on
sait que chaque situation est différente
c'est de regarder ça de manière
attentive sur le long terme et c'est
pour ça que je disais tout à l'heure la
science et l'innovation au cœur de tout
ce que l'on doit faire et c'est pour ça
qu'on a lancé un observatoire de
l'éolien en mer 50 millions d'euros
justement pour continuer à avoir ses
études et pour et ton capacité de
rectifier quand il y a rectifier mais
soyez bien assuré que développement des
énergies renouvelables va de pair avec
protection de la biodiversité on
continuera à avoir cette éthique là
cette méthodologie là et par exemple
même quand un parc n'est pas dans un
parc naturel marin ce qui est le cas par
le rond il doit y avoir un avis de
l'office français la biodiversité il y
aura des avis environnementaux il y aura
encore une une un regard très précis et
des réponses qui devront être apportées
par les porteurs de projets et les
autorités environnementales seront au
cœur de la prise de décision donc on
continuera le faire quand on regarde
l'exemple européen et bien on voit que
les deux le ballet de paire mais on est
très attentif à tous ces sujets donc on
continuera de le faire sur la question
j'ai répondu sur le sujet sur la
question de la taxation fiscalité
d'abord
je prends bonne note de votre de votre
invitation et je viendrai en Normandie
avec grand plaisir dès que c'est
possible sur la question de la fiscalité
vous avez raison pour l'instant la
fiscalité
avant la ze c'est 50% pour les communes
35% pour les pêcheurs 10% pour le FB et
puis 5% notamment pour la SNSM qu'on
arrive en Z2 c'est une fiscalité qui
pour l'instant irait exclusivement au
budgétaire alors déjà je tiens à dire
quelque chose quand même parce que le
budget d'État ça veut pas dire l'état le
budget de l'habitat après ensuite peut
servir à financer des politiques de
pêche peut servir à financer des
collectivités locales peut servir à
financer un stand de projets donc faut
pas voir ça le budget de l'État comme un
trou noir loin de là c'est quelque chose
qui permet justement parfois
d'équilibrer entre une région qui a plus
ou qui a moins et je crois beaucoup
moins l'aperéquation je crois beaucoup à
la redistribution et donc il faut pas
l'écarter comme ça par définition parce
que l'État par contre la question que
vous posez les légitime et donc les
section avance je viens pris de notes de
toutes les demandes notamment des
présidents de région ce qui est sûr
c'est que quand on va en Z2 il y a des
sujets technologiques techniques qui se
qui se forment donc c'est plus coûteux
et donc faut qu'on regarde ça de manière
à la fois très sereine mais aussi avec
beaucoup de de précautions parce qu'il y
a des coûts qu'on ne connaît pas encore
tout de suite et donc avant de réfléchir
à la répartition de la fiscalité
regardons quels seront les impacts les
coûts que ces projets auront mais en
tout cas ça fait partie des discussions
que l'on a sur bien évidemment faire en
sorte que la la fiscalité de ces projets
là en ze puissent se bénéficier au
maximum de personnes et donc on aura le
discuter je crois dans les prochains
mois pour regarder comment tout ça se
répartit sur la notre ambition pour la
biodiversité monsieur le sénateur vous
avez raison de l'évoquer cette année a
été une année particulièrement riche en
événement internationaux et aussi
nationaux sur les enjeux de biodiversité
marine vous savez qu'il y a eu le One
nation Summit à Brest ou le président de
la République a réaffirmé au fond
l'océan comme une des priorités
notamment pour faire face aux
changements climatique et le président
se rendra à la Coop 27 climats
sharm-elcher et puis un septembre de
ministres iront aussi a priori j'ai reçu
mais il faut qu'on fasse ça avec tous
les différents ministres donc je peux
pas encore totalement confirmer mais en
tout cas il y aura une représentation du
président de la République et des
ministres à haut niveau et puis ensuite
la COP 15
à
Montréal au Canada sur les enjeux aussi
là aussi de biodiversité et donc il y a
eu vous savez le sommet des Nations
Unies aussi des océans à Lisbonne ou le
président de la République a réaffirmé
son ambition sur notamment les aires
marines protégées en France on a cette
on veut et on continuera à tenir cet
objectif de 30% des marines protégées
notamment protégé
partout sur le territoire avec 10% de en
zone de protection fort et notamment 5%
en zone de protection forte en
Méditerranée et donc là le travail est
engagé avec le avec le ministère la
transition écologique avec tous ceux qui
aussi portent financent ces parcs pour
tenir cet objectif qu'on a déjà tenu
d'ailleurs sur les aires marines
protégées de 30% mais pour aller plus
loin sur les zones de protection forte
nous on a un modèle de protéger ou on
met la conservation au cœur de ce modèle
là où on n'empêche pas parfois un
certain nombre
d'activités et donc on a au fond une
cohabitation des usages ça se passe très
bien par exemple dans le parc naturel de
la mère d'Iroise par nationale parc
marin d'Iroise Parc national des
Calanques parc du Golfe du Lion donc on
a des modèles d'air marine protégés
différentes en France mais je crois
qu'ils sont regardés avec beaucoup
d'attention par un certain nombre de
pays partenaires ensuite on a une
ambition aussi à l'internationale
j'étais à New York en août pour la
négociation du traité bbnj c'est au fond
c'est
la biodiversité en haute mer la haute
mer c'est 65% des océans c'est un espace
qui n'est pas régulé et donc la France
et j'étais le seul ministre des pays
représentés on a porté vraiment une
ambition à trois niveaux la première
c'est de pouvoir créer des aires marines
protégées en haute mer puisque pour
l'instant c'est un espace au fond qui
est laissé
à la main de de pays en tout cas
d'entreprises qui sont peu regardantes
de l'environnement et de l'impact sur la
biodiversité et de dire il nous faut
créer des air marines protégées et
surtout avoir les modalités de pouvoir
les contrôler et de pouvoir vérifier que
elle soit effective en mettant au coeur
non pas la gestion simplement mais la
conservation c'est à dire qu'on doit
préserver la biodiversité marine ensuite
il y avait un deuxième aspect et qui
tenait beaucoup à cœur aux pays en
développement c'était au fond le partage
des ressources génétiques ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que si jamais demain
en haute mer on trouve une molécule qui
permet des avancées médical des avancées
pour la recherche scientifique ça ne
peut pas être la loi du premier arrivé
premier servi et donc que ça doit être
reconnu comme un bien commun de
l'humanité et que donc l'océan
appartient à tout le monde et donc il ne
peut pas y avoir d'appropriation par tel
ou telle pays et puis le troisième
aspect sur lequel la France a beaucoup
porté et sur lequel on a beaucoup avancé
c'est aussi pour avoir un mécanisme
d'études environnemental très précise et
la plus pointilleux possible pour toute
activité en route mère c'est pas facile
parce que on part de très loin il y a
beaucoup de pays qui sont pas du tout
sur cette position là mais de dire qu'il
faut constamment vérifier l'impact
environnemental de nos activités c'est
un élément pour nous qui est important
indispensable pour préserver ce bien
commun et pour faire en sorte que la
haute mer ne devient pas un espace
qui est sous au fond sous l'empire de la
dérégulation
donc voilà sur les aires marines
protégées et on le fait avec dans le cas
de la stratégie nationale de la
biodiversité et on le fait en lien avec
le ministère de la transition écologique
pour préserver nos littoraux et pour
préserver les
océans notamment aussi dans les
outre-mer sur l'enjeu de la scène vous
ça me permet de revenir sur ce point
d'abord ce n'est pas la France
on dit ce n'est pas la France qui a
porté quoi que ce soit sur le sujet
c'était un amendement qui était porté
par une parlementaire européenne et
c'est le Parlement européen qui dans le
cadre du trilogue c'est à dire la
réunion entre le Conseil la Commission
et le Parlement c'est le Parlement qu'il
a abandonné pourquoi puisque cet
amendement viser non pas interdire la
scène danoise mais viser interdire
l'utilisation de la scène danoise
uniquement pour les bateaux néerlandais
et belges ce qui remettait en cause les
fondamentaux de la politique de pêche
commune puisque on a un accès on a la
question de la
libre accès aux zones notamment de tous
les pays européens et donc si cet
amendement prospéré l'Europe dans son
ensemble a considéré que ça remettait
totalement en cause les fondamentaux de
la politique européenne des pêches
communes et donc qui ne pouvaient pas
passer ce qui ne veut pas dire que la
France et c'est même je vais vous dire
c'est même plutôt l'inverse ne veut pas
de régulation de cet enjeu de la scène
d'ailleurs on l'a fait pour la nouvelle
Aquitaine mais au niveau région entre
les pêcheurs on l'a fait aussi en
Bretagne ou la scène danoise n'est pas
autorisée à dans
l'espace et donc nous ce que l'on porte
et c'est un discussion qui porte depuis
2009 depuis 2009 cette question de la
régulation à scène danoise c'est qu'elle
se fait dans le cadre de des commitaux
des comités régionaux de pêche et c'est
dans ce cadre-là que ça va se faire
depuis 2009 la discussion est sur la
table moi j'ai demandé au service de
l'État en lien avec le pêcheur de
relancer cette discussion là pour
aboutir à une négociation et surtout
pour aboutir à des actions très
concrètes et donc la France en lien avec
l'Europe porte pour cette régulation de
la scène danoise parce que comme vous
l'avez très bien dit ça devient un sujet
quand on le voit que dans cette partie
de de la Manche il y a les impacts du
brexit qui sont encore là il y a une
multiplication des navires et donc il
faut que mais il faut qu'on avance en le
faisant dans le bon cadre dans le bon
cadre et si on n'avait pas eu cet accord
en
22 sur ce texte là ça ré-aboutit à quoi
pas d'accord libéralisation totale des
eaux au premier janvier
2023 et ça je crois que aucun pays
européen ne le souhaitait et donc c'est
pour ça que le Parlement européen
lui-même a abandonné cet amendement donc
nous on va continuer de défendre la
pêche artisanale on fait tout pour qu'il
y ait une libéralisation qui n'est pas
de libéralisation pardon de nos eaux
c'est pour ça que un syndrome de pays
n'ont pas porté cet amendement là et on
va continuer à défendre la pêche
artériale c'est pour ça qu'on a
notamment mis en oeuvre les interburants
les interburants bénéficient d'abord aux
pécheurs artisanaux c'est pour ça qu'on
lance la décarbonation de nos navires
qui bénéficie d'abord à nos personnages
artisans c'est pour ça qu'on se bat pour
la gestion plus annuelle des quotas qui
bénéficient d'abord aussi au pêcheurs
pour qu'ils aient de la visibilité et
d'après visibilité dans leur
aussi actions d'investissement donc vous
voyez nous on est dans une stratégie où
que ce soit de la Corse la Méditerranée
du golf de Gascogne en passant par la
Manche on défend une pêche artisanale en
lien avec les territoires en lien avec
des outils de transformation qui sont
territorialisés qui sont localisés et
c'est pour ça qu'on a tout fait pendant
la crise du covid qu'on a tout fait
pendant la crise du brexit pour soutenir
les licences de pêche pour nos pour nos
péchures artisanaux et qu'on continuera
à le faire en termes d'investissement et
en termes de moyens et sur votre
dernière question à Madame sur le les
projets au fond
hydroliens alors il y a l'usine Marie
motrice qui est en Bretagne qui
fonctionne bien qui fait l'objet de
Lourdes investissements parce que c'est
il y a en termes de maintenance c'est
c'est quelque chose qui est important
d'ailleurs visité cette usine Marie
motrice qui avait été inaugurée par le
général de Gaulle il y a fort longtemps
et donc on va continuer à
financer tous les projets innovants qui
permettront de répondre à ce triple en
jeu réduire notre réduction réduire
pardon notre dépendance aux énergies
fossiles accélérer le développement des
énergies renouvelables et autant se
faire le peu le faire en mer et donc
c'est un appel à l'innovation à tous les
projets qui existent on le fait avec la
DM on le fait en lien avec les
institutions publiques et on continuera
de le faire partout sur toutes les
technologies mais c'est vrai que ça
prend un peu de temps et on sait que le
temps pour lutter contre le changement
climatique
manque et donc c'est pour ça qu'on va
aussi sur des technologies qui sont
éprouvées comme l'éolien posé ou
l'éolien flottante quand c'est possible
et sur le projet de d'Afrique du Sud
parce que vous avez raison c'est pas un
projet porté du tout pour l'État c'est
un projet qui est porté par une
entreprise privée on va regarder ça de
manière très précise après il y a un
pays qui est souverain qui s'appelle
l'Afrique du Sud c'est à lui d'abord de
répondre sur ces enjeux de protection de
la diversité mais croyez bien que nous
tous les projets soutenus par la France
doivent et seront des projets notamment
dans le cadre des projets de l'Agence
française de développement des pays qui
des projets qui sont à destination de
pays en développement émergents sont des
projets qui doivent répondre à notre
ambition commune pour la préservation
des océans donc j'ai pas d'infos sur ce
projet qui a un projet privé et en tout
cas ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
la France ne soutient pas des projets à
l'international qui visent à mettre à
mal la biodiversité marine
merci je vais donner la parole à
Monsieur gilet
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre on a bien entendu votre
ambition concernant la stratégie
nationale
des taureaux
mais j'ai du mal à
concevoir et avoir quelle sera la
position et le rôle du Conseil national
de la mer et des littoraux concernant
justement cette stratégie
on a même le sentiment qui pourrait y
avoir une forme de confusion
au niveau des objectifs et des travaux
entre le cinéma et en même temps le
laboration de la stratégie nationale
donc si vous pouviez nous donc clarifier
la place du CNML par rapport à justement
cette cette ambition et puis puisqu'on
parle du CNL
sa présidente aujourd'hui a travaillé
sur un amendement donc au niveau du PLF
pour la création donc d'un fond
d'érosion côtière qui est un sujet qui
est relativement important vous le savez
par rapport aux obligations
d'un certain nombre de communes sur ce
sujet là j'aimerais connaître votre
position concernant cette initiative
parlementaire il êtes-vous favorable
puisqu'elle est soutenue par un nombre
relativement important de parlementaire
et se font se récré à partir d'une
taxation complémentaire sur les droits
de mutation
pour venir alimenter donc pour venir
justement l'alimenter
concernant un autre sujet sur la
stratégie portuaire on a quand même du
mal aujourd'hui à visualiser en termes
de programmes pluriannuels
d'investissement
les objectifs et les réalisations sur
l'intermodalité
vous nous affichez effectivement des
intentions des volumes financiers mais
actuellement aujourd'hui on a des
difficultés véritablement à évaluer les
efforts qui sont faits dans ce domaine
c'est un sujet qui est absolument
essentiel aujourd'hui pour améliorer la
performance des ports maritimes et pas
uniquement même également des portes
fluvio et donc si vous pouvez m'apporter
également quelques éclairages sur le
sujet je vous remercie merci chers
collègues la parole à Monsieur Bigot
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre Frédéric personne ne conteste
aujourd'hui il a nécessité du mix
énergétique et l'éolien offshore fait
partie de ces nécessités d'autant plus
que c'est une technologie qui est
techniquement au point et puis en plus
la France a une façade maritime
extrêmement importante donc il faut donc
exploiter comme on voit d'autres pays
l'ont fait comme le Danemark notamment
vous nous avez dit que vous étiez vous
vérifiez le choix de maintenir
l'activité halieutique tout pendant les
la durée des travaux
vous savez que le costard américain que
vous êtes le 16 en août le c'est
sûrement beaucoup de questions se posent
notamment au niveau des des producteurs
et des professionnels les producteurs de
coquilles Saint-Jacques par exemple se
demandent si la biodiversité ne va pas
être altérer et que la ressource
s'épuise au bout d'un certain temps je
crois que là dessus la science pourra
nous apporter des réponses mais quels
sont les réponses que vous leur faites
vous parce que l'inquiétude est réelle
et il faut que nous les consommateurs on
puisse également leur répondre et puis
sur les questions environnementales vous
avez vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure la
nécessité de travailler en amont avec
les populations notamment sur les
façades maritimes on a vu que pour
Saint-Nazaire il y avait eu quelques
hésitations sur au large de Quiberon et
sur l'île d'Yeu c'est un peu la même
chose donc le travail en amont de
concertation est la population va être
extrêmement importante notamment pour
les questions environnementales je
voudrais vous interroger sur une
deuxième question sur l'usine marée
motrice de la Rance et la capacité de
production de ce type d'installation
comme vous le savez les marées ne sont
pas toujours égales il y a des fortes
amplitudes des moins fortes amplitudes
donc la production d'électricité n'est
pas la même en fonction des marées c'est
un modèle économique qui a été installé
en 1966 au temps des trentes glorieuses
où il fallait l'indépendance de la
France personne ne le conteste mais
aujourd'hui le bilan économique vous le
connaissez monsieur le ministre ce
modèle n'a pas été dupliqué il avait été
envisagé notamment de le dupliquer dans
la baie du Mont-Saint-Michel ou ailleurs
ça n'a pas été fait tout simplement
parce que ça n'est pas rentable de mon
point de vue est-ce que vous pouvez nous
éclairer sur ce sujet merci merci la
parole de Monsieur marchand merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je voudrais profiter de votre
présence parmi nous et vous remercier
pour tous les éclairages que vous nous
apportez pour évoquer la situation de
l'outre-mer et relayer les
préoccupations de nos collègues
ultramarins et de la population
ultramarine quand au potentiel
économique de la pêche et de l'accue de
l'aquaculture ultramarine qui reste
aujourd'hui à développer un rapport une
étude a été publiée par France agrimaire
en 2019 et faisait état de nombre de
difficultés et notamment le retard pris
dans la modernisation des flottes de
pêche or on voit bien et nous sommes
certains à avoir pu nous déplacer sur
ces territoires que des opportunités de
diversifications sont identifiées
existent et donc si vous pouvez nous
apporter quelques éléments que nous
pourrions partager
avec nos collègues sur votre feuille de
route s'agissant spécifiquement de cette
question de l'outre-mer merci
merci chers
bémol sur le concert de louange qui vous
a été adressé puisque nous nous sommes
pas encore rencontrés dans mon
département et je le regrette vivement
je suis sénateur de Saône-et-Loire et je
voudrais tout de même vous rappeler
qu'au Jurassic supérieur la mère
recouvrait la totalité de la Bourgogne y
compris le Morvan le Beaujolais même le
Charolais dont je suis l'élu donc ça
doit vous donner quand même une certaine
légitime légitimité à venir nous voir
sans parler des portes de plaisance sur
l'assaut et sur le canal du Centre qui
se connecte bien sûr au maire et océan
plus sérieusement vous avez rappelé
l'importance de la superficie maritime
de notre pays qui représente 17 fois la
superficie terrestre
les enjeux sont essentiels également en
politique en matière de politique de
grands fonds marins
exploration protection et exploitation
de ces fonds marins ce sont d'ailleurs
les enjeux qui ont examiné nos collègues
sénateurs lors d'une mission
d'information cette année il
s'interrogeait sur la gouvernance sur le
débat entre exploration et exploitation
sur les enjeux de souveraineté également
en la matière et donc j'aurais aimé
avoir votre sentiment sur cet enjeu là
comme on vous l'aborder dans le cadre de
vos de vos responsabilités quelle
position française sur l'exploitation
minière des fonds marins internationaux
également et puis quel partenariat
internationaux la France envisage-t-elle
d'avoir en matière de bassin ultramarin
et puisqu'on parlait de transition
énergétique tout au long de cette
réunion de commission bien sûr chez nos
concitoyens y compris ceux de
Saône-et-Loire ce qui n'ont pas la
chance d'avoir un port ou des côtes ils
sont quand même très attentifs bien sûr
à la transition énergétique avec les
batteries avec les métaux rares avec une
éventuelle pénurie et donc est-ce que
est-ce que la peut nous garantir que la
France en la matière ne sera pas soumise
à une nouvelle pénurie
merci la parole est à Monsieur laelec
puis à madame avait pour terminer
merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le ministre
[Musique]
merci aussi pour toutes les précisions
que vous avez bien voulu apporter j'ai
retenu que dans la feuille de route si
je puis dire la priorité aller à la
protection de la biodiversité marine
donc la priorité n'est pas au cas
particulier que nous évoquons ici la
production d'énergie la deuxième
priorité m'avait vous dit nous avez vous
dit c'est le développement des activités
de la pêche
donc ce n'est pas non plus le
développement énergétique et ce n'est
que dans le troisième volet si je puis
dire que c'est à dire la coordination en
mer que la thématique de la production
d'énergie en mer trouve sa place
ceci mais si je me trompe vous
rectifierez mais ceci me conduit à
considérer
qu'il ne faut pas confondre vitesse et
précipitations dans les objets que nous
allons devoir définir en matière de
production d'énergie
et dans le même temps il y a des
adaptations qui devraient être possible
il en est une que j'entrevois dans
l'exercice que nous allons devoir
conduire c'est l'adaptation des
délaissés portuaires s'ils peuvent être
utilisés pour produire de l'énergie je
pense que ça soit une bonne ce serait
une bonne chose que de l'adapter mais en
même temps je pense qu'il ne faut pas
dénaturer la raison d'être de la loi
littorale donc vous voyez on est un peu
dans cet exercice toutefois une
opportunité s'ouvre à nous pour pouvoir
le faire et je pense que nous serons
plusieurs dans notre Haute Assemblée à
être tenté d'envisager cette hypothèse
je parle pas à la place des collègues
mais ça me paraît opportun c'était donc
une première remarque et si je peux vous
avoir des éclairages là dessus ça
m'intéresserait beaucoup la deuxième
remarque que je veux faire c'est que
quand on aborde des espaces portuaires
il est bon de se voyez ici qu'il n'y a
pas que les grands ports maritimes
il n'y a pas que les grands ports
maritimes pour maintenir un petit
une petite illustration que vous
connaissez un peu la Bretagne
administrative
qui a quand même 2700 km de côte
si on ne considère que les GPM par
rapporter la question maritime nous
n'avons pas de port en Bretagne
perts
donc or ceux de Brest de Lorient et de
Saint-Malo ont été transférés par des
lois Raffarin de 2004 et ses
installations existent bien il faut bien
s'en occuper et si je me permets de le
pointer ici c'est parce que
le nouveau dépositaire de ce magnifique
pratiquement c'est la région Bretagne
qui perçoit en tout et pour tout
en dotation globale de décentralisation
un million et demi par an pour ces trois
ports
ce qui quand même
créé une situation particulière pour ses
collectivités donc je pense qu'il est
bon d'intégrer quand même à la réflexion
le fait que ces portes décentralisées
existent
et
il convient aussi
à partir de là d'apprécier la situation
particulière que constitue la desserte
des hymnes toutes les régions de France
n'ont pas des îles
et encore moins celles dont la mère
s'est retirée depuis quelques années
mais il se trouve qu'il y a des régions
il y a de la dessert des îles et à
organiser et par conséquent la question
de la décoration des moyens pour s'y
rendre se posent aussi dans des termes
particuliers avec des investissements
particuliers envisagés donc voilà ce que
les quelques remarques que je voulais
faire et puis monsieur le ministre
saisissons l'opportunité de cette
rencontre dont je me permets de vous
remercier pour vous donner l'occasion
peut-être de repréciser en quelques mots
l'appréciation que vous portez sur le
port cryolien en baie de Saint-Brieuc
il s'est écrit beaucoup de choses
là-dessus je voudrais que l'occasion
nous soit donnée ici de lever toutes les
ambiguïtés si vous en étiez d'accord
merci en tout cas
après la Bretagne je vais donner la
parole à la Bretagne
alors apparemment le Finistère a gagné
1000 km de côte donc il y a plus que
2700 km de côte sur la Bretagne
monsieur le ministre je voudrais juste
revenir en fait sur les propos du
président de la britannique il y a
quelques temps qui appelait à la sortie
du moins 10 ans social destructeur sur
le 30 le transmanche entre autres depuis
l'arrivée l'an dernier d'un avis Irish
ferry qui est sous pavillon chypriote et
si vous pouvez nous indiquer en fait
quelques éléments qui pourraient être
mis en place à un autre niveau et
surtout au niveau européen sur ces
sujets je vous remercie
c'est le ministre
sur la première question qui était un
collègue sur
le Conseil national de la mairie du
thorax en fait pour repréciser les
choses c'est dans le cadre du Conseil
national de la mairie électorale en tout
cas avec ce conseil national que l'on
Nova déployer la stratégie nationale de
la mer électorale puisque c'est le forum
pour le faire et donc il n'y a pas de
duplication il n'y a pas de doublon
c'est on a la chance d'avoir une
institution qui existe qui permet de
représenter au fond tous les acteurs on
a la chance d'avoir une stratégie qu'on
doit renouveler
snml pardon et donc c'est dans ce cadre
là qu'on va la faire et je veux vraiment
en faire plutôt que de réinventer
quelque chose plutôt de refaire un autre
cadre stratégique d'utiliser ce qui
fonctionne d'utiliser ce qui reconnut
comme un espace de discussion de
délibération et de du coup de déployer
de discuter de travailler
et d'affiner cette stratégie nationale à
la mairie électorale d'ici la mi 2023
dans le cadre du Conseil national de la
mère électorale c'est comme ça que on le
conçoit et bien évidemment que chaque
région chaque espace a parfois ces
modalités de discussion mais c'est là
que devra se faire la convergence de
toutes ces discussions là et dans ce
cadre-là sur le sujet de du fond des
raisons côtier écouter si une initiative
qui est toute récente en tout cas vous
dire que le gouvernement a déjà des
lignes qui existent sur l'érosion
côtière c'est 10 millions dans une des
lignes c'est le plan de relance plus de
4 millions il me semble qu'ils sont
aussi disponibles il y aura le fond vert
aussi qui a été annoncé par le Premier
ministre sur lequel on peut aussi
imaginer qu'il y ait ce rassemblement de
de lignes qui sont parfois un peu dans
différents ministères en tout cas sur le
fond avoir des moyens supplémentaires
pour permettre de lutter contre les
raisons côtières c'est une bonne idée
maintenant il s'agit pas de multiplier
les différents canaux donc il faudra
qu'on regarde ça dans le cadre des
différents textes budgétaires dans le
cadre de la stratégie aussi nationale
qu'on a déployé sur
la lutte contre l'érosion côtière donc
je découvre comme comme vous aujourd'hui
cette cette idée je pense qu'il la bonne
chose à retenir c'est qu'on a une
ambition collective pour faire face à
ces enjeux qui sont qui sont immenses et
donc qui nécessiteront je crois un
travail collectif donc voilà on aura
l'occasion de regarder très précisément
mais en tout cas il y a déjà des choses
qui existent et qui sont qui vont
permettre parce que au fond ce qu'il
faut c'est déployer très rapidement les
premiers projets et donc avec les
crédits qui sont disponibles on peut
commencer déjà à déployer les premiers
projets après c'est vrai qu'il y a une
stratégie à long terme parce que si on
se projette à 2100 ça sera une autre
histoire il faudra des financements et
des recettes qui sont un peu différentes
sur
de la multi modalités vous l'avez évoqué
il y a déjà des projets donc pour être
encore plus précis par exemple
travailler sur les infections il y a la
connexion ferroviaire avec le port de
fausses qu'on va continuer de développer
elle a chatière au Havre il y a le
travail que l'on fait avec les armateurs
pour justement modifier le prix de la
manutention pour permettre cette
multimodalité parce que avant quand vous
utilisiez le le ferroviaire au fond
c'était pas très incitatif et donc il y
a un travail qui fait avec les armateurs
pour que cette multimodalité ne soit pas
pénalisante pour tous ceux qui
l'utiliseraient donc c'est d'avoir des
des mécanismes de prix qui sont
incitatifs au report modal et donc c'est
ça qu'on travaille avec eux donc il y a
plein de projets comme ça concrets
partout dans nos ports sur l'impact sur
les coquilles vous êtes pas censé savoir
si vous êtes constamment récurent aussi
que on n'a jamais eu autant de coquilles
que cette année c'est une saison record
donc là aussi
il faut
si si les travaux sont lancés depuis un
petit moment donc mais faut faire
attention c'est que là aussi la science
est importante corrélation n'est pas
causalité
coïncidence mais encore moins causalité
donc ce que l'on peut dire c'est que il
n'y a pas de pluie le lancement des
travaux d'impact négatif sur la coquille
mais c'est pour ça qu'on a cette
observatoire de l'éolien en mer pour
regarder à chaque étape de la
construction à chaque étape du
déploiement l'impact qu'il pourrait y
avoir nous on est très attentif et je le
suis en tant que Star américain très
attentif à la ressource halieutique
parce que au fond elle a été
magnifiquement bien préservé par les
pêcheurs depuis des dizaines et des
dizaines d'années et donc il faut que ça
continue d'être le cas donc on y sera
attentif dans le cadre des travaux
scientifiques qui ont été lancés et pour
l'instant on ne peut pas dire qu'il y a
un impact ce qui ne veut pas dire que
n'aura pas dans 10 ans mais il faut pas
non plus qu'on joue à se faire peur pour
l'instant le depuis le lancement des
travaux on ne peut pas tirer de
conclusion négative sur le développement
de ce parc et et le la production
actuelle ou de cette année le montre sur
l'usine marée motrice vous l'avez
parfaitement explicité c'est vrai qu'il
y avait un projet à un moment donné dans
la baie de du Mont-Saint-Michel c'est
n'a pas été fait en tout cas nous ce que
l'on souhaite continuer à faire c'est
que cette usine Marie motrice de la
Rance continue à tourner parce que elle
rendait service
économiques environnementaux dans nos
production énergétique qui sont
incroyables alors en effet elle n'est
pas à l'équilibre financier parce que
c'était un prototype parce que c'est des
coups de maintenance qui sont importants
mais je crois que c'est un élément
important de la transition aussi
énergétique de la production énergétique
de ce territoire donc on va continuer de
la soutenir et on va se battre pour que
notamment au niveau européen soit
reconnu comme tel et donc qu'on n'arrive
pas à un démantèlement comme parfois
certains le laisseraient penser de cette
usine c'est que on a un une entreprise
EDF qui la gère avec la plus grande
précision avec le souci d'en faire une
vitrine et d'ailleurs c'est un des des
bâtiments un disciple de production les
plus visités de Bretagne et donc je
crois qu'il faut continuer d'en faire un
élément de de fierté et donc oui elle
n'est pas à l'équilibre mais en même
temps elle apporte beaucoup de bienfaits
donc il faut continuer à la soutenir
avec un sujet sur la question de la
tarification verte mais ça c'est un
autre débat qu'on ne pourra avoir une
autre fois sur les outre-mer mon cher
collègue
les outre-mer vous avez raison il faut
qu'on ambition très forte sur les
outre-mer parce que on ne peut pas avoir
un développement notamment économique de
ces territoires si on n'a pas une
ambition très forte sur le développement
des flottes de pêche et de l'activité de
pêche et donc on a trois enjeux par
rapport à ça un c'est continuer à
investir dans les ports et donc il faut
qu'on le fasse avec les différentes
collectivités c'est pour ça que dans la
réunion avec
tous les ports et je réponds à Gérard
laelec il y aura pas que les grands
ports dans la réunion avec les ports
c'est aussi les portes décentralisées
parce que ça fait partie de ces
stratégies nationales que l'on doit
avoir et donc il y aura aussi des ports
ultramarins et puis c'est le combat
qu'on mène avec Jean-François caraco qui
a été mené depuis aussi 2017-2018 sur la
modernisation de la flotte et de la
modernisation des règles qui nous
permettent de changer les bateaux on a
des bateaux qui datent de 30 40 ans
parfois en outre-mer c'est inadmissible
c'est inacceptable et ça crée d'ailleurs
de la tension politique ça crée de
l'incompréhension de la part de nos
concitoyens dans les outre-mer sachent
en plus ils voient parfois des navires
d'autres pays venir aussi payer leurs
ressources ou en tout cas péchés dans
des eaux qui ne sont pas les leurs donc
le combat qu'on mène c'est un combat
pour faire changer ses règles au niveau
européen on va continuer à chaque fois
que je vois le commissaire SIM qui
vicius
en échange avec lui Jean-François caraco
s'est rendu à Mayotte pour aussi porter
ce combat là nous d'ores et déjà pour
montrer notre volonté on a mis en face
en place fondamentage de décarbonation
des navires de pêche de 6 millions
d'euros pour dire que voilà nous on est
prêt à investir dans la décarbonation de
données vers de pêche et j'ai pas
d'espoir qu'on sera entendu parce que
c'est un élément de souveraineté aussi
et de développement économique pour ces
territoires on a aussi un enjeu sur
développer les métiers liés à la mer
dans les territoires
ultra marins et donc ça ça veut dire
continuer aussi avoir une coordination
des différents lycées maritimes une
coordination de la formation pour aussi
mieux l'adapter aux spécificités des
territoires
ultramarins donc on va continuer sur le
sujet là les crédits sont disponibles
maintenant il faut qu'on ait une
adéquation de ces règles européennes
pour que moderniser les bateaux qui
permettent d'attirer d'ailleurs des
jeunes ne soient pas vu comme
nécessairement
la con enfin ne soit pas vue comme une
de la capacité de pêche c'est une
modernisation d'un bateau un bateau plus
grand c'est plus confortable ça attire
des gens dans les métiers qui est
difficile et donc ça il faut que tout le
monde le comprennent sur le point de
l'exploration et donc ça me permet de
rectifier quelque chose que j'ai dit
tout à l'heure je parlais de 80 millions
d'euros parce que je parlais des projets
qu'on a évoqué dans la phase numéro 1
mais l'ambition que l'on a les crédits
disponibles pour l'exploration France
2030 c'est 350 millions d'euros j'ai dit
80 millions parce que je parlais de ce
qu'on avait évoqué ce qui était d'orgé
déjà engagé et donc nous sur l'enjeu et
je remercie vraiment tous les sénateurs
qui ont participé au débat je trouve
très intéressant que l'on a eu au Sénat
c'est on est sur l'exploration
l'exploration uniquement la recherche
scientifique la connaissance parce que
nous considérons que c'est la priorité
et parce que l'exploitation
implique des risques environnementaux
implique des choses que je crois nous
pas
comment dire soutenir financer ou
une voix dans laquelle nous devons nous
engager je sais que c'est un peu
orthogonal avec ce que vont peut-être
faire d'autres pays mais nous je l'ai
dit tout à l'heure la priorité c'est
doit être aussi la protection des océans
la protection de la biodiversité marine
et donc l'exploration oui et comme l'a
dit président de la République à
Lisbonne l'exploitation non et donc
d'ailleurs on a modifié le code minier
en France qui fait que nos engageons pas
dans l'exploitation dans nos eaux et
donc on essaie de convaincre et on
convainc
à chaque réunion nos partenaires de ne
pas s'engager dans cette voie là non pas
qu'on ne
considère pas qu'il y a un enjeu sur
tout ce que vous avez évoqué mais qu'en
tout cas la priorité face aux enjeux de
dérèglement climatique soit nécessité de
préserver la biodiversité doit être et
bien d'abord et uniquement l'exploration
je sais que c'est pas forcément facile à
tenir dans le concert de des nations et
que un certain nombre s'engage dans
cette course là
au minerai et autres mais je crois que
pour les futurs générations c'est ce que
la ligne que l'on doit tenir en tout cas
c'est celle que le Président de la
République et le gouvernement tient par
contre on a une ambition très forte sur
l'exploration avec 350 millions d'euros
sur des missions avec les frères sur des
missions avec des scientifiques sur des
missions pour aller explorer les fonds
marins plus de 3000 plus de 6000 et donc
là on va continuer à porter cette
ambition très fort dans les outre-mer et
en lien avec tous les acteurs de la
science notamment le CNRS
sur l'enjeu des énergies marines
renouvelables posées telles quel par le
sénateur Gérard Elec en disant que au
fond dans la dans la
dans la dénomination des priorités les
énergies marines renouvelables
arrivaient en troisième alors déjà en 3e
sur multiples priorités c'est déjà bien
et puis surtout que les trois priorités
ça veut dire un deux trois et je crois
que quand je dis la priorité doit être à
préservation aussi des océans ça
implique du coup réduction des CO2 et
donc développement des énergies
renouvelables et donc développement des
énergies marines renouvelables donc
c'est pas antinomique c'est je crois
complémentaire cohérent et on va
continuer à le porter sur les ports je
vous ai répondu mais vous avez raison
c'est pour ça que la Réunion il y aura
des ports décentralisés qu'on continuera
à intégrer au maximum dans tout ce
réseau dans toute cette ambition les
ports qui sont gérés par parfois des
départements au parfois des raisons sur
le parc de Saint-Brieuc costard
américain je crois que là certaines
peignent de découvrir une position qui a
la même depuis que je suis député j'ai
toujours dit que ce type de projet ne
pouvait pas se faire n'importe et à
n'importe quel prix n'importe comment et
n'importe quel prix en 2018 le président
de la République s'est rendu au Cap réel
pour justement
rediscuter de ce projet rediscuté du
financement de ce projet parce que
justement il y avait des choses à
ajuster on a eu et vous le savez aussi
bien que moi monsieur le sénateur un
préfet en 2019-2020 qui est arrivé et
qui a permis de remettre tout le monde
autour de la table de reprendre les
discussions de reprendre la concertation
et donc la position qui est la mienne et
qui est d'ailleurs aussi celle du
gouvernement qui est de dire on doit
faire les choses de manière la plus
concertée possible on doit mettre au
coeur de cette stratégie de
développement des EMR la planification
et donc c'est la ligne qui a été la
mienne depuis 2017 c'est la ligne qui a
la mienne depuis que je suis au
gouvernement c'est ce que j'ai dit au
pêcheur costard américain premier
déplacement que j'ai fait c'était pour
aller voir les pêcheurs que ça
américains pour dire que ce projet
allait continuer en ayant à cœur la
concertation en pensant des gens le
retour
des usages une fois que le parc serait
déployé et donc je crois que en la
matière comme vous d'ailleurs monsieur
sénateur le gouvernement et moi-même on
a fait preuve de cohérence on a rectifié
la trajectoire quand ça partait dans le
mauvais sens et encore une fois quand
j'évoque cette expression de mon
grand-père maternel qui est ni fainéaire
ça veut dire que quand on tire les
leçons de ce projet là et bien il y a
des choses qu'on aurait dû faire
différemment et c'est une bonne leçon
pour les futures générations et sur le
les futurs parcs à déployer et à
développer et je sais que vous partagez
cette expression de mon grand-père mon
cher sénateur Laennec et sur le modèle
le modèle social merci beaucoup madame
sénatrice chez hernadette je sais votre
implication sur les sujets aussi de
dubbling social en effet ce sont des
pratiques
utilisées par un stand de d'entreprise
qui sont déloyales qui sont
inacceptables parce qu'au fond un mal
notre pacte social et le pacte social
européen et donc nous pour avoir des
entreprises qui opère avec le plus haut
standard social environnemental en
termes de salaire aussi et donc on va
travailler avec le gouvernement
britannique pour trouver des modalités
d'avoir des des modèles sociaux
similaires je crois que le Président de
la République notamment dans le cadre de
la PFE à redit aussi notre ambition et
bien de travailler sur le renforcement
de notre société et de lutter contre le
dumping social parce que c'est un enjeu
de souveraineté c'est un enjeu de
sécurité aussi et donc là on le lâchera
rien et donc on fera en sorte que comme
on l'a fait sur les travailleurs
détachés m'ont rappelés en 2017 et que
c'était pas vu comme quelque chose de
très simple en continuera le faire sur
les marins sur les gens de mer et donc
on va travailler très concrètement pour
renforcer
la lutte contre le dumping social et on
a des genres des états une mission qui a
été lancée au sein de mon ministère
trouver des pistes très concrètes et
aussi des moyens coercition si jamais on
n'arrivait pas à avancer et empêcher un
certain nombre de bateaux qui se
livrerait à ce dumping social de pouvoir
opérer sur ce tranchement donc on a
beaucoup d'ambitions on travaille très
concrètement avec une inspection avec
une mission d'inspection et je n'ai pas
de doute sur le fait qu'on va pouvoir
avancer avec vous parce que je sais que
ça tient à coeur à tout laisser natures
qui regardent cette question du dupping
social au fond comme une remise en cause
de ce qui doit être le projet européen
et ce qui a été porté pendant des
nombreuses années par un certain nombre
de nos prédécesseurs
bien monsieur le ministre je tiens à
vous remercier
pour la clarté de vos propos et vos
réponses et puis l'énergie que vous
mettez à défendre vos dossiers merci
pour cet échange et puis ma foi on se on
va se mobiliser pour les deux trois
quatre novembre afin que on soit très
présent sur ce sur ce dossier
d'accélération des énergies
renouvelables merci Monsieur le Ministre
merci beaucoup